In the previous video, we got
a feel for how regression trees
can do things linear
regression cannot.
But what really matters
at the end of the day
is whether it can predict things
better than linear regression.
And so let's try that right now.
We're going to try to
predict house prices using
all the variables we
have available to us.
So we'll load the
caTools library.
That will help us do
a split on the data.
We'll set the seed so our
results are reproducible.
And we'll say our split will
be on the Boston house prices
and we'll split it 70%
training, 30% test.
So our training data is a
subset of the Boston data
where the split is TRUE.
And the testing data is the
subset of the Boston data
where the split is FALSE.
OK, first of all, let's make
a linear regression model,
nice and easy.
It's a linear model
and the variables
are latitude, longitude, crime,
zoning, industry, whether it's
on the Charles River or not,
air pollution, rooms, age,
distance, another form
of distance, tax rates,
and the pupil-teacher ratio.
The data is training data.
OK, let's see what our
linear regression looks like.
So we see that the latitude
and longitude are not
significant for a linear
regression, which is perhaps
not surprising because
linear regression didn't seem
to be able to take
advantage of them.
Crime is very important.
The residential zoning
might be important.
Whether it's on
the Charles River
or not is a useful factor.
Air pollution does
seem to matter--
the coefficient is
negative, as you'd expect.
The average number of
rooms is significant.
The age is somewhat important.
Distance to centers
of employment (DIS),
is very important.
Distance to highways and
tax is somewhat important,
and the pupil-teacher ratio
is also very significant.
Some of these might
be correlated,
so we can't put too much stock
in necessarily interpreting
them directly, but
it's interesting.
The adjusted R squared is
0.65, which is pretty good.
So because it's kind
of hard to compare out
of sample accuracy
for regression,
we need to think of how
we're going to do that.
With classification, we just
say, this method got X% correct
and this method got Y% correct.
Well, since we're doing
continuous variables,
let's calculate the sum
of squared error, which
we discussed in the original
linear regression video.
So let's say the linear
regression's predictions are
predict(linreg, newdat960
of the picture and
the right-hand--
So the left-hand
side of the tree
corresponds to the
right-hand side of the map.
And the right side of
the tree corresponds
to the left side of the map.
That's a little
bit of a mouthful.
Let's see what it
means visually.
So we'll remember
these values, and we'll
plot the longitude
and latitude again.
So here's our map.
OK.
So the first split
was on longitude,
and it was negative 71.07.
So there's a very handy
command, "abline,"
which can put horizontal
or vertical lines easily.
So we're going to put
a vertical line, so v,
and we wanted to plot
it at negative 71.07.
OK.
So that's that first
split from the tree.
It corresponds to being on
either the left or right-hand
side of this tree.
We'll plot the-- what we want to
do is, we'll focus on one area.
We'll focus on the lowest
price prediction, which
is in the bottom left
corner of the tree,
right down the bottom left
after all those splits.
So that's where
we want to get to.
So let's plot again the points.
Plot a vertical line.
The next split down towards
that bottom left corner
was a horizontal line at 42.21.
So I put that in.
That's interesting.
So that line corresponds
pretty much to where
the Charles River
was from before.
The final split you need to get
to that bottom left corner I
was pointing out is 42.17.
It was above this line.
And now that's interesting.
If we look at the right side
of the middle of the three
rectangles on the
right side, that
is the bucket we
were predicting.
And it corresponds to that
rectangle, those areas.
That's the South Boston low
price area we saw before.
So maybe we can make that
more clear by plotting, now,
the high value prices.
So let's go back up to where
we plotted all the red dots
and overlay it.
So this makes it
even more clear.
We've correctly shown how the
regression tree carves out
that rectangle in
the bottom of Boston
and says that is
a low value area.
So that's actually
very interesting.
It's shown us something
that regression trees can
do that we would never expect
linear regression to be
able to do.
So the question we're going
to answer in the next video
is given that regression trees
can do these fancy things
with latitude and
longitude, is it
actually going to help
us to be able to build
So you can see it is pretty much
the same as the other commands.
Wow okay.
So those are all the points have
got above-average pollution.
Looks like my office
is right in the middle.
Now it kind of
makes sense, though,
because that's the dense
urban core of Boston.
If you think of anywhere
where pollution would be,
you'd think it'd be where the
most cars and the most people
are.
So that's kind of interesting.
Now, before we do
anything more, we
should probably look at how
prices vary over the area
as well.
So let's make a new plot.
This one's got a few
too many things on it.
So we'll just plot
again the longitude
and the latitude for
all census tracts.
That kind of resets our plot.
If we look at the distribution
of the housing prices (Boston
MEDV), we see that
the minimum price
(remember units are
thousands of dollars,
so the median value of
owner-occupied homes
is in thousands of
dollars) is around five,
the maximum is around 50.
So let's plot again only the
above-average price points.
So we'll go:
points(boston$LON[boston$MEDV>=21.2].
We can also plot the latitude:
boston$LATboston$LAT[boston$MEDV>=21.2].
We'll reuse that red
color we used for MIT.
And one more time, with
we'll do the solid dots.
So what we see now are
all the census tracts
with above-average
housing prices.
As you can see, it's
definitely not simple.
There's census tracts of
above-average and below-average
mixed in between each other.
But there are some patterns.
For example, look at that
dense black bit in the middle.
That corresponds to most
of the city of Boston,
especially the southern
parts of the city.
Also, on the Cambridge
side of the river,
there's a big chunk there
of dots that are black,
that are not red, that are
also presumably below average.
So there's definitely
some structure to it,
but it's certainly
not simple in relation
to latitude and
longitude at least.
We will explore this
more in the next video.